E aí
G1
[Música]
eu quero para mim que eu pego do feito
tudo que acredito tudo que a gente faz
de bom sabe que ele falta briga se foi
muito ruim não mudou sempre tá tudo bom
sabe que comigo não tem essa porque a
vida já me pegou muita peça pega para te
mando que eu tô com pressa ele olha para
mim com a galera maluca maluca que mata
o trabalho beijando ele sonhar você tem
que ser bolha papai tá tudo bem tudo
certo de bom então tá tudo bom tudo bem
Tudo bom Jesus tem lugar que eu já fui
que está terminado e não chegou
iluminação e aquele que promete a mesma
que te rouba e ainda aperta a tua mão ou
levanta terminar só metade da educação
depois vai reclamar porque chama os
gambé quando some uma saem os carrinhos
de mão eu falei para ela que eu filhos e
mundo e também um jeito de fazê-la por
os amigos não tinha um bom que nós vamos
aqui só tava só
tu não fala não é que Lembrava que
controla Mas sol é realmente eu te jeito
era isso aí agora foi de meu irmão manda
para mim que eu pego nos feito tudo que
acredito não quer ir para
quem sabe aquele pata briga se foi muito
ruim não mudou também rápido bom sabe
que comigo não tem essa porque ajuda que
ele pegou muita peça pega para te mando
que eu tô com pressa não
E aí
[Música]
oi
para mim que eu pego do certo tudo que
acredito tudo que a gente participam
sabe que ele falta briga se foi muito
ruim não mudou tudo bom sabe que comigo
não tem essa não quero dizer que ele
pegou meu café da Fátima não que eu tô
com pressa não
E aí
[Música]